nos gars n'a pas l'habitude de nous avec
une barbe quel rôle préparez vous êtes
une barbe will préparatoires et les
fonds encore fourni à pour les besoins
d'un film que je fais pour la télévision
mais longtemps le fait d'être à la
comédie française n'était pas un bon
point pour le cinéma les producteurs et
les metteurs en scène moderne ont
toujours les mêmes idées je le crains
oui d'ailleurs c'est au fond pas tout à
fait justifié et assez normal ce sont je
crois qu'en france ce sont deux métiers
de cellules très différents entre très
très cloisonné que le cinéma a besoin
quelquefois davantage de personnages
plus d'acteurs et enfin les constats
sont là le fait d'être au théâtre
français
favorise pas la carrière au cinéma
''cela veut dire bien sûr on va faire
une carrière au cinéma
à l'exemple de quelques camarades
confrères illustre c'est assez difficile
vous conseillerez vous conseilleriez un
débutant de passer par la commune
française
ah ça oui je crois que tout acteur qui
est sollicité par la comédie française
ne doit jamais hésiter je crois que tout
acteur devrait passer par la commission
ne s'est pas possible bien entendu mais
tout acteur devrait elle devrait passer
pour la comédie française c'est pas moi
qui le dit c'est jean louis barrault si
un jeune acteur démarre au boulevard où
la pièce marche très bien il joue la
même pendant deux ans et c'est un peu le
bureau ou ne marche pas très bien il est
obligé d'en trouver une autre etc
d'étirer sa nette et c'est assez
difficile
je crois qu'on se on se prépare
moralement a des choses à des exigences
si vous voulez en entrant théâtre
français qui ne faut pas négliger c'est
un espèce de service militaire et
roulait à peu prolongée qui en a les
difficultés des vertus et c'est pas une
hutte
[Musique]